that you're such a a nice guy a sweet
presence you're so amiable but man you
have a scary face well I
it's funny you should mention that
because I always thought that even no
emotion whatsoever I have a scary face
period I I have that uh kind of uh
resting face that is has scorned and
anger well look of consternation and
intensity so if for instance okay if I'm
looking at this camera no emotion
whatsoever the the thing that you read
is fear
[Applause]
so I look I look that already then you
enter a real dilemma and boy it just
compounds wow and people think that I'm
I'm actually thinking of something and
I'm like right now when I'm talking to
you I'm actually thinking of lunch